エイ
僕は
スーパーガールズが大好きです
アイドルオーダーてみたいなアイドルなんでも大好きだぜとわけじゃないんですけど
結構いろんな音楽に行きますよ洋楽もたまに聞きますして10歩好きだしてないどれも
好きだしアニメも大好き結構いろんな曲恍惚の3つのみ好きなんですけどもうアイドル
というカテゴリの中で僕はですねスーパーガールズというグループがですねもう3年前
からずっと浜でしてて超好きなんです
いや本当にいい理由は王道なんですよ暴動んじゃあアイドルみたい
みんな可愛くてなんでも甘い声も綺麗じゃあいるんですよそのスーパーガール二曲も
ある音楽アプリ
あー紹介でございます俳句わーんというアレ
すっごいいろんな楽曲も数百万曲といいきゃっ
基礎登録が必要なくすぐ使えるプレイリストを作るんですけどいろんな人とプレイ
リストを聞けますそして機能的でデザインがとてもお洒落な音を射程な感じのアプリ
アワーでございます
そんなね数の音と付けるのに3ヶ月間無料
プレイリストがすぐ見つかるで色んな曲に出会うとが簡単見ていきます
コンサートにアカウントを作ったわけなんですよ
今回僕は皆さん10をお見せするプレイリストはこちらですこれが僕のプレイリスト
スーパーガールズをプレイリスト作りました
ポストね
behance
ana
ani
落ち着くよってそこで今回ですねなんと今回直接
僕のを占めてるスーパーガールズの by しまー3さん網谷 os 行きたい
いただきました
あれ
このプレーに自動もっと楽しんでもらうために僕は直接で毎週はさんに会ってその
スーパーガールの良さとかねこの二集 part 素晴らしさを引き出すために直接
会ってお話ししてきたので僕だ place とにある曲のこともちょい高話できたの
でよかったらね
スーパーガールどんなアイドルなのか見たはどんな人なのかとかね色んなことがわかれ
ばいいと思いますどうぞ
いやまず緊張したからねぇ
いつも通り沿いですよね
ま一部亜美さんにお越しいただいていますどうぞ
it 指で今回のゲストはこちら
スーパーガールぞすみませんはい本当にちゃんスーパーが sos もんです高校3年
生の17歳ですよろしくお願いしますじゃあ
なぜな話をするとあの本当のファンなんですけどうれしい
元気をいただいております
ブーブー色さっ
それを行うときは15歳とか14です
せっかくお会いする機会を頂けたらちょっと行けつか質問をしたいと思っております
けどお答えしていただけるとね有り難く存じ上げている
このように住んでよします最近ハマっていること休みとかありますか
最近は以後ニャティティてるんでしょ
も強いんですか全然強くないんですけど雨変調2という
今後ですねはい
どのような活動をしていきたいですか観覧は空をアイドルとしてもいいですよまん
しゅうまさんとしてでも
そうですね入るんですよ
俳優さんを目指してらっしゃるんです俳優はいじゃああーそういうソリューション
くらいのグループとしては般若さんみたいに国民的な web になりたいらしい
思ってるんですけど個人的には4倍になっていったか
なんかそういう好きなことを伸ばしていけたらなんですよね
the girls の
どんなところが
他のアイドルとこう違うというのは魅力というかポイントが終わっ
スーパーガールズは王道のアイドルグループてぃ
塗って今年の6月に消し募集年になったんですけどあのエムボグぐるさんとか
電波 b さんとか結構個性的なアイドルさん多いじゃないですか
なんですけど super girls わぁ校合同でアイドルだったらこれだなんて
言う日曜はビット付するによっているのでそこなんですよだパリでそこなんですよね
ただメジャー6元ビジョンにせずはいじゃあアイドルみたいなメンバーがコース首
すって王道大事にしてるアイドルなんですよねそう言うん
村瀬言わせてしまうああああいう形のオススメの1着はこの8月19日に発売する
姉さんもあります入っちゃってヤっちゃう思っていますこれなー新曲に見えるのでぜひ
行っていただけたら嬉しいです黒子の頭いってください
じゃあそれで僕は何ですけど頑張って選手がべっ
も何が元気でるんだ
ああああああ
直径現地ノズル直径はない
フィンガーん
すごいライブで盛り上がるのがギラギラレオ兄さん
あれ着ないですねそうなんですよ2打目
入れる日
ですそれぞれこれからのスパナ日
センターがエリスが私5周年います
全国を回りプリーキャンペーンやってるふりちょっとブルーできるんですよねねっ
鈴をかもしれません静岡
すぐ行くは色々と全国の方にスパ語を知って頂きたいなっていうと思う
萌え度 c やっていうことで結成3周年目にやらせていただいたんですけどもう一回
4ブドウが選ぶ選挙の急に
いきます何で売れたといっしょとりますか
あごめんなさいよく取れるんですこれ以上ないんですよね
ビニール傘みたいな本日の jester スーパーカーズ舞洲見たんでしたーー
いやーいいですか
で今回僕のオススメするこのあーのプレイリストハイ編
熱のこもったものでございますいい曲なんですよいい区別し電気が出るそしてずばが
付くかわいいそんなね俺の今週のプレーで人是非みなさん聴いてくださいえっと僕の他
にもですねと四角いちゃんアバンティーズ bds ダンテ
編みビューティーチャンネル生菌さんとミクさんですねパワーの動画をアップしてるん
でよかったらそちらもチェックしてみてください僕のプレーして寝る発見
以外にもいい曲はたくさんあるのでぜひね色んなちゃんのプレイリストも見れるので
是非を使ってみてください
じゃじゃーん
ん
はぁん